this is uh from Fox News thousands
protests sisters of Perpetual Indulgence
outside Dodger Stadium hours before
start of Pride night and we can see
someone Super Chat as Bill M saying
Dodger Stadium entrance shut down by
protests
so for those aren't familiar this is a
hate group whose sole intention is to
insult and mock Christians and Catholics
in particular and they are being given
the opportunity to to perform uh their
hate speech at Dodger Stadium now for me
I'm all about the First Amendment stuff
like that so typically it's like you
know if you're going to have a group and
they want to speak their mind and they
want to put on a show or whatever I'm
typically okay with it however in Los
Angeles they have very very strict rules
against this so it's it's surprising
that law enforcement allowed this hate
speech to persist and uh and and forced
the good citizens seeking social justice
to come and protest I would also want to
know why the hell so many things have
nothing to do with drag shows now have
to do with Dragons what does Sports have
to do with it right everything who the
hell in the in the good name of middle
management was like you know what would
be a good idea we should have this group
like what does that have to do with
baseball giving uh Straight girls who
make Pride about themselves I feel like
it drag has never ever been as popular
until all of these people who had no
interest in dag decided we needed drag
shows everywhere but I want to pull up I
have this tweet from uh Savannah
Hernandez thousands of Catholics have
shut down the main entrance to Dodger
Stadium on Vince Gully Avenue in protest
of the Citrus sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence being honored tonight they
are now lining the sidewalks and have
taken over the entire block I mean this
is what we're talking about talking
about conservatives who need to to stand
up and protest and I gotta point out too
I probably shouldn't even say
conservative many of them probably are
many of them may be Catholic but uh
Savannah says thousands of Catholics
perhaps there are thousands of Catholics
but I'm willing to bet there are a lot
of just regular angelenos who are like
Hey we're not okay with this kind of
performance this Minstrel show and not
all Catholics are conservative right
there are liberal Catholics who would
see this as an insult to their faith
it's like we forget that there are
pro-life Democrats they're a minority
yeah but their party gave them away we
don't talk about these things because we
have decided that you know most are like
this but if you were a left-leaning if
you were a liberal Catholic this would
be just as insulting to your Faith as if
you were a conservative I do have a
feeling that Sheamus would tell you
there aren't liberal Catholics there are
I know there definitely are but are they
really Catholics then if they're
appalling I mean I think there are a lot
of Catholics who disagree about Vatican
can you be a pro-choice Catholic
no I would say no but I am not a
practicing Catholic it's not my my
decision to uh well what I will say is
there's certain certain things and this
kind of gives me hope a little bit
there's certain uh areas of weakness
like cracks in the structure of the left
where they lose their own party and I
think these are some of the ones you see
like the trans issue the vax issue you
know when they get too extreme on
certain issues that go against Common
Sense Minnesota just didn't Minnesota
just legalize late term like late late
term abortion and that was just I
believe so that was just like just a
couple of years ago I was talking to
someone because like I said I'm from
Minnesota and I was talking to someone I
was explaining about Ralph Northam and
what was going on and all of these
things are like that sounds crazy that's
not real I'm like no no you have to read
this you have to read the bill you have
to read through all these things uh and
then they're like well that's that's
very Fringe that's not going to expand
that was a couple years ago and like
that will never come here I'm like
that'll come here before it'll come a
lot of a lot of other places given the
way that Minnesota is uh BLM activists
who just got arrested in Canada or
charged in Canada uh for an
anti-catholic hate crime she blocked a
Catholic school and couldn't like people
can get in I guess and uh she was also a
very serious
um pro-abortion activist she led a huge
rally in Calgary and was interviewed and
she was saying we need to speak out
about the potential this is after the
row uh decision leaked and she was
saying we need to speak out because
what's happening in America could spread
to Canada they could take away our
rights to abortion uh if if they think
it could happen shouldn't we think it
could happen right you know I thought
the timing of the Roe v Wade uh decision
was a bad move for conservatives I
thought it really hurt I had a big
debate with my dad at the time he's like
people don't care as much as you think
I'm like people are single party voters
and they vote emotionally and you know
uh when what's his name from Barstool
Sports uh came out and was like I'm
voting left if they they go on fortnite
made some kind of speech about voting
democratic this happens and I was like
man people people are so so weird in
their decision to just like outrageously
like no no no that makes sense for
Portland I mean his argument and I'm not
I'm saying this with in all seriousness
I thought his argument was that if he
knocks up a woman he doesn't want to
have the kid oh that's a fair argument
for being pro-choice I personally find
it morally
um as I find it to be morally repugnant
yeah but at least he's consistent in his
uh but I don't wanna I don't want to
assign views to him I don't know if
that's 100 sure I just remember people
saying something like I think he said
something about that like yo I feel like
up with a chicken she gets she gets
pregnant or whatever like you gotta have
that choice or something like that
that's what it's because of ease a
society of ease let me just double check
that I'll make sure I'm right no but
that makes sense I mean that really does
make sense yeah plenty of friends who
are like yes I am very in support uh
support of your abortion rights because
I don't want to have to take any
responsibility if I screw up or we
always say it's women but I think there
are a lot of men who are like no please
everything everything that women are
pushing nowadays men are secretly very
like women are like I want the right to
be promiscuous it's like I wasn't Andrew
Schultz do a whole bit about this he's
like we agree feminine he's like he goes
the feminists of today are the F boys of
five years yeah guys are like what do
you tell me you don't want me to pay for
you you don't want to work free the
nipple yeah I agree yeah yeah do you
want to pay for all this stuff so dude
let's get down here let's clarify I
don't have anything of him saying
anything like that he's literally just
giving the traditional uh left argument
women's Choice it's their right
Constitution Etc all right I mean I mean
either way I'm sure there are other men
who have made that argument I I sort of
disagree I think you know obviously it
was bizarre for the for the leak but I
think the timing of Roe v Wade was good
for the conservative base I think
conservatives felt like it was a win
like yes maybe there were moderates who
got freaked out by it and moved the
other way but you're always battling
over maybe they could have gotten that
one after them I think that's that's
what the timing of it is no I think I
mean midterms are are a debacle in a lot
of ways but I think generally seeing
that the Supreme Court was going to
change this decision was something that
uh helped conservatives I think they
felt like it re-energized them because
it for so long I think a lot of
conservatives feel like they are
battling an uphill uh they are battling
uphill to defend their values and keep
them here they're always having to
compromise on everything and it was the
one time in a long time that they have
been like oh no we were right this was a
bad idea the Supreme Court says it
should go back to the stage which was
the also the crazy thing because the
left went into hysterics about this and
they were like you're challenging
abortion everywhere it's like kind of if
your state wants to have it you can and
yes it does again it's the messaging and
there and and the right never gets an
opportunity to put out the right message
you'll never get the media to to back a
message that's right so like I've even
made arguments to people who uh are very
left-leaning and I've gotten them on
board with uh with it by just saying I
don't think the government should have a
say one way or the other because they
could eventually lead to a complete
restriction on it if you feel like they
should be uh which is what they try to
ask Trump about at the Town Hall like
this is they are only operating they
only want this to be a federal issue the
fact that this is the compromise it's a
state's issue as it always should have
been is not enough I disagree I don't
think it should be a state issue really
yeah I think uh overturning Roe v Wade
is wrong it should be a federal issue it
should be Federal federally regulated no
I feel like you think it should be
federally regulated yeah I think I'm I
don't know exactly what my view was
around the time this was overturned I
think we were all fairly in agreement
over it we've had a lot of conversations
about it and I think that it should be
Federal federally regulated under the
14th Amendment
um or because of the 14th Amendment I
think the federal government has to
ensure uh equal rights under the law to
to all life
that doesn't mean I think abortion
should be banned I don't I think it just
means that we can't have two standards
of when someone is allowed to get an
abortion because it terminates a life
there is no point in history where an
arbitrary definition of personhood has
not resulted in the math Mass death of a
group right and and so you know where we
are is I I'm traditionally I'm in the
more traditional pro-choice Camp which
is up to a certain amount of weeks
government stays out of it after a
certain point it's the baby can survive
the baby should not be killed that's my
view I think the federal government
should regulate it of course rovey Waits
overturned so it doesn't matter but um
it could go to Congressional legislation
if Trump and Republicans sweep you could
end up with like a 12-week nationwide
ban if the federal government yeah I
just feel like it should always we
should always defer power to the states
rather than the federal government I
believe I agree with you we want to have
a an equal application of uh equal
protection under the law and I I
personally believe life begins a
conception right but I think putting
power in the hands of federal government
is always a mistake but then you're
saying that California has the right to
restrict free speech
how so this is the 14th Amendment
question do we as life human life have
equal rights under the law the answer is
yes we do well the question then becomes
and you're making the argument if by
your own argument then there should be a
complete ban of abortion across the
board no conception nope the the issue
is when it comes to two by two two life
forms inhabiting the same body I don't
believe the federal government has the
right to order someone provide their
body and blood to another person there
you go there's a competing rights issue
with abortion absolutely so you have two
bodies however how can we at
acknowledging this that there's
competing rights allow two different
states to have two different standards
for what the Constitution is supposed to
enforce so that means it's up to
federally uh it's up to the federal
government to interpret or for
legislation to codify how the 14th
amendment should apply to unborn persons
the left's principal argument is life
doesn't begin a conception they have to
make that argument otherwise the fourth
amendment is clear abortion is
completely illegal
um or I should say restricted up until
like 12 to 16 weeks I do not see how you
could argue the Constitution guarantees
the rights of all citizens except we
allow the states to determine when and
where those rights start and stop right
you can't well the problem is again with
definitions of personhood and again I
think any or any made-up definition of
personhood other than it is a human life
you know by your own definition is a
dangerous one even in a competing rights
issue because you're comparing two
different rights you're not competing of
the right to life with the mother to the
right to life of the fetus you're
comparing the right to terminate because
of dependency to the right to life and
so the right to terminate or the right
of dependency is a much lesser right
than your right to life in other words
if I connected you to me right now and
we had a Accord by my own choice by my
own action I forced your dependence onto
me and I said now that you are dependent
on me I have the right to kill you you
would say well no my right to life is
bigger than your right especially that
it is through your own action to depend
on me now you can make the argument in
rape and instance in those cases that
doesn't hold because I don't think the
incest one applies because there's no
yeah as long as there is no consent to
the ACT that argument makes sense but
when you take action to create a life
and then you try and say well there's a
competing rights issue no it's not an
equal right and you took action to
create that right through consent to
create that situation through concern
early on I was very much saying like oh
it's good that the states are taking
control of this issue which it should go
to the states and things like that now I
I I very much don't think so because of
the Constitution and because of the 14th
Amendment thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time